foreign
[Music]
so we do an sg1 Revival
we get RDA we get Sam we maybe do that
idea that we suggested about
um I mentioned this on the video last
night as well we did that video about
the
um
there's a sect of go award like cult
members and they're trying to bring
Anubis back
um and that's the whole film is about
what's trying to stop them huh
would a film LED by Richard Dean
Anderson Amanda tap in Michael Shanks
Christopher Judge
with a new team as well on the side so
it's led by the original sg1 but in that
film they basically hand the Baton over
to a new team
would that
for one do you think it would be
successful at the cinema could it be
successful at cinema and two would that
tick all of your boxes from a Gator's
point of view
yeah
yes
somewhat
foreign
works
touche
[Laughter]
just a right sort of there's some sort
of magic ancient machine that can draw
in ascended being that would be so peace
well I mean they did it with the or I
didn't know there's a machine that can
just kill ascended beings oh how
convenient
yeah
I left it behind the sofa
the ascended being killing machine
no no actually
that could work because that kills
that kills ascended beings and Anubis
was half ascended they killed the
Ancients obadasala is fully Ascent oh
so no half of them is bad
and it just pulls his body of course his
being back into a body or something an
Anubis magnet
um no no no ignore the magnet we're
talking about the the Ascender killer
now I know but then it would freeze yeah
I I get that yeah yeah okay use that one
however they do it however they decided
to do it you know they will take up a
perfectly logical way of doing that and
then they will think up some Cinema way
of doing it that will all go what why
did that work but anyway it doesn't
matter however they do it they're trying
to release Anubis they're trying to get
Anubis back that's the point of the
movie and then
um but it's the the point of the oldest
you want team and a new sg1 team I I
could see that it's an sg1 team so
that's we see the program as it is now
and there's an sg1 team but because of
what's going on they need the knowledge
of the original SG-1 team to come back
and it's a bit like um I mentioned
yesterday Top Gun and Maverick are they
need that those people with the
knowledge to come back and help the
younger inexperienced team who have
never even fought the goal of all don't
forget they won't have even they would
never have fought the gold at that point
um and I just think that's that would be
a really cool and I think it would be
but if you've never watched Stargate you
wouldn't have a freaking clue what was
going on yeah
uh and there's another thing Maverick is
an ensemble film
it's following Tom Cruise one of the Old
Guard would this film be following one
of the Old Guard or would it be
following one of the new guard and is
the new guard a team of four or is it
just like another
uh Joe Flanagan like Like a Shepherd
situation and we find the team along the
way
I wouldn't mind if it was just one
person and like the new but that's the
thing if the new guards in there or if
the old guards in there
and they're leading them to some big
something I think the only way to handle
that is to kill off a bunch of them
honestly and I don't want to kill off a
bunch of sg1 but if it's if it's an sg1
movie and you're introducing new sg1
that's that's a lot well it immediately
goes from four people to eight people if
you do another sg1 team
so and that's a lot of money there's a
lot of actors
because of the way Stargates worked
historically they they've just moved up
the ranks and now they were in
administration positions where you don't
see them on screen as often but at this
point ever at all again at this point
how are they going to go up we've had a
man with them for 15 years they're all
going to be generals they're all going
to be Admirals they're all going to be
these freaking huge things there's not
going to be anywhere else would be a
general we know that um some would be a
general not necessarily be in Stargate
command we'd hope she is Jack is
obviously now a retired General
um will be a draft for somewhere leading
Jaffa probably yeah and Michael Shank oh
sorry Daniel Jackson would be
um maybe the the the the what the
non-government program leader of SGC or
something yeah
maybe it's his idea that to bring
so whatever it was would have to be
related to an episode in Stargate sg1
so that would be a planet they've been
to a mission they've been on something
there would have to be something
specific that you have to bring them
back
you know what I mean because they know
how to get through you know this this
isn't this isn't what they do but it's
there's a maze the story is amazed they
have to get through and only the
original unless you want to know how to
get through it I'm not being literal
there I'm being you know like
the only issue you want to know how to
get from A to B on this job so they have
to bring them in to do it and it could
be Daniel who's the civilian leader of
the SG parties there's no's there's this
we need Jack
and we need Sam and we need to look
you know
um and that's right and sg1 you're gonna
have to take them but another problem is
though
isn't that a film we've seen a million
times it's a film we've seen a million
times and if they don't kill people off
people are going to be pissed off at the
end because it's going to feel like
nothing happened it's Space Cowboys
isn't it with Clint Eastwood and think
that's maybe that's where I'll get this
idea from so watch Space Cowboys about a
month ago
you know you've got the young astronauts
and they need the older astronauts
because they're the only ones who know
to do it um boom um but
that's not a bad thing because I mean
virtually every film or series you've
that's ever been made you can go over
it's very similar to something else that
came before written oh yeah
so that's not necessarily A Bad Thing
it's a trident that's a good thing about
Stargate is if you do kill off every
single character from from before they
can still come back because they have
the Multiverse
and they've got Daniel Jackson yeah
since he died was it six times
[Music]